my speaker tonight attended
undergraduate and law school at Temple
he practiced law he served in the
Justice Department under the great ed
meese he became the hand of the landmark
legal foundation he began a radio show
which is the fastest growing and one of
the largest in the land he is the author
of three best-selling books most
recently liberty and tyranny which has
sold more than a million copies these
are great and wonderful things and I can
interpret the man for you
the reason I can do this is because I
have known him since 1996
I spent some serious time with him in
the summer of that year when he was a
lincoln fellow in claremont where i was
working and i can tell you some things
about him he was nice back then
I have a fellow who works with me in the
college his name is Kenny Cole and he's
a wrestler by trade and I mean he when
he was a high school guy he's actually
the chief financial officer of the
college and and but he's a wrestler
that's his nature and I notice about him
that if we're having a meeting and
something bad is happening and somebody
says well you know we have to you know
be careful here we can't really Kinney
is always the one who you know he's like
John they're two John's like this too
you know if you work with people a lot
it's like war and you come to love them
and know them really well and he always
takes this little half step forward
right mark turns to face the enemy it's
like a dog who likes to hunt you could
see in him back then that although you
couldn't imagine the particular dispute
the National Education Association
should be careful because if they're
actually in fact going to break the law
it might cause them trouble
somebody might not be afraid but there
is also about him another thing he is a
student with that combination of
assertion and humility that make
learning possible we found this
determined and aggressive man who you
know by the way he was a lawyer and
these days they think they know about
the Constitution they actually think
that the Constitution is a string of
court cases you know which is another
idea that's stupid
you know it's stupid it it can't it
should not survive the laughs test and
so we thought about this guy we thought
you know he's this lawyer you know and
we and I confessed you when I was
younger I was a little cocky
and we thought we're really gonna teach
this guy what happened was we loved him
right away and he taught us because he
disappeared and we disappeared and there
was only the things that we were
studying and the beauty of them was
apparent to us to each other one another
as fellow students and he comported
himself with service and humility and we
loved him for that
and today I mean in in an intermediate
day if you can imagine an immediate day
from back then when he wasn't famous to
now when he's like this big cheese
we used to name who are the best of
these guys who came through there Steve
Hays is on Fox News he's another one of
them he's a very very fine man if you
see him on TV you could just look at him
and you say somebody who really knows
him knows this is a fine guy and that's
what we think about this guy and I will
tell you the last two days three days
I've been going around talking only to
the very best members of Congress I was
able to have meetings with them all
there aren't many
but you know Peter Roskam was here
earlier Peter has a daughter at
Hillsdale College he will do whatever I
say he is a great man he's marvelous
John Shattuck I've known him forever Tom
McClintock used to work for me and I
went around with them and I said
something that I will now say if my
friend right here
the philosopher as we call him Aristotle
writes that the highest human
association is friendship and friendship
is reserved for those souls who have
dissin disciplined themselves to put the
best things the highest and to recognize
that in one another and he says that
friendship binds the city together and
makes it work and I will tell you then
two things and the first one is the
people who govern us today underestimate
the force of that and the second is I
introduced to you my friend Mark Levin
I'm speechless go to a commercial or
something
well Larry Arne is everything you hear
he's brilliant he's faithful to his
family in his country he's a patriot and
he runs the finest educational
institution in the nation
and he's turned it even into a better
educational institution and what's so
unique about Larry is he's not only
creating the future statesman of this
nation and God knows we need them but
right now today is trying to reach out
to the American people from that campus
in the middle of Michigan really in the
middle of nowhere can't you move the
damn place I'll be perfectly honest it's
actually a beautiful campus they tell me
it's 90 miles from Detroit should be 200
miles from Detroit well I don't give a
lot of speeches this year I'll give
three
I gave one at the Federalist Society in
March I'll give one at the Reagan
Library and I'm giving this one tonight
because this organization means an
enormous amount to me and if we don't
reach the next generation it's over and
I'm being perfectly honest about this
the key to America's greatness is the
civil society Aristotle Cicero
Montesquieu Locke Burke Smith the
founding fathers they all addressed it
in one form or another the civil society
recognizes the individual as unique
spiritual being with a soul and a
conscience
it's built on a transcendent moral order
as Edmund Burke and many others have
described it in the civil society the
individual has a duty to provide for
himself and his family he has a duty to
be a good citizen he contributes
voluntarily to the well-being of his
community church and
and it respects the unalienable rights
of others the civil society has a
cultural identity that consists of
traditions and values and customs tried
and tested over time and passed from one
generation to the next
as Larry was talking about and in this
civil society private property and
liberty are inseparable
the individual is right to live freely
and safely and to pursue happiness
includes the right to acquire and
possess property property is the
manifestation of the individual's
physical and intellectual labor to
illegitimately seize it is to enslave it
a just and predictable rule of law
provides the governing framework that
undergirds and nurtures the civil
society in our case the United States
constitutional for the conservative the
preservation and improvement of the
civil society is paramount if we are to
maintain a humane and free country for
the alternative is one form or another
tyranny the modern liberal is not
liberal at all the classical liberal is
the opposite of an authoritarian the
modern liberal is a statist that is he
promotes what the Tocqueville accurately
described as a soft tyranny now what do
I mean by this the statist is at war
with the civil society he rejects the
Declaration of Independence which says
in part we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal that they are endowed by their
creator with certain unalienable rights
that among these are life
liberty in the pursuit of happiness
these are words rarely taught in our
elementary schools today for the statist
individuals pursuing their own
legitimate interests living independent
and self-sufficient lives largely
unencumbered by government is an
intolerable conditioner and it's about
time that we stop giving the status the
benefit of the doubt and accept the fact
that he does not share our passion for
liberty and the good that flows from it
the statist is basically a malcontent
he's miserable about his circumstances
and he blames it not on himself but on
his surroundings on other people on
society generally he searches for
significance and even glory and a
utopian fiction of his mind's making the
earthly attainment of which he believes
is frustrated by those who do not share
it so he sets out to destroy the civil
society and that is exactly what Barack
Obama and Congress are doing today now
on the other hand we conservatives
understand that Liberty is precious and
once lost is rarely recovered we know of
the fall of past republics we know that
the best the best way forward is not by
further empowering and already enormous
federal government beyond its
constitutional limits but to return to
the founding principles a free people
living in a civil society working in
self-interested cooperation and a
government operating within the limits
of its authority promote more prosperity
opportunity and happiness for more
people than any alternative
conservatism is the antidote to tyranny
precisely because its principles are the
founding principles one of the most
effective yet pernicious tools of the
statist is language Abraham Lincoln
explained it this way and I'm so taken
by this quote I put it on the back of my
book we all declare for liberty but in
using the same word we do not all mean
the same thing with some the word
Liberty may mean for each man to do as
he pleases with himself and the product
of his labor while with others the same
word may mean for some men to do as they
please with other men and the product of
other men's labor here are two not only
different but incompatible things called
by the same name Liberty and it follows
that each of the things is by the
respective party's called two different
and incompatible names liberty and
tyranny so for the status tormenting us
controlling us dictating to us ceasing
from us is explained as Liberty for the
rest of us it's tyranny the status
misuses the word equality and to great
effect as he pursues uniform economic
and social outcomes and in this regard
he promises to make that which is
imperfect perfect and that which is
impossible possible if only you will
surrender more and more of your liberty
and property to him only then can his
utopia such as it is be achieved
consequently the status rejects rights
is being unalienable instead he assumes
the authority to determine who has
rights and who does not and rations them
accordingly last year in his
commencement speech to the graduating
class
wells lien University Barack Obama made
the point among other things he said our
individual salvation depends on
collective salvation
well salvation is not government's to
give it's not a grant to mankind from
mankind and under the wrong conditions
and in the wrong hands this deviant view
is a powerful tool against humanity he
didn't say that I said that
and yet this is where we are today
although the soft tyranny has been
building for decades the most brazen and
dangerous war against the civil
societies being waged as we gather here
now by this president in this Congress
they are scheming against the individual
Liberty private property the rule of law
and ultimately future generations and
they are pushing on multiple fronts in
less than 10 months Obama and
congressional Democrats have in effect
nationalized many of our largest banks
by using tarp funds to buy their stock
they vive the nation's bankruptcy laws
by turning Chrysler and GM over to the
UAW and unsecured debt etre and
strong-armed secured investors their
nationalizing the stood alone system
they are claiming the power to dictate
lending terms offered by mortgage
companies and interest rates by credit
card companies they seek to dictate
management salaries and bonuses and in
certain industries they seek to compel
unionization of the workforce that is
voting without a secret ballot Obama and
Congress have used the recession to
launder tens of billions of dollars in
phony stimulus bill money to their
favorite political constituencies
including acorn the SEIU and politicians
and bureaucrats and state local
governments in fact so irresponsible
arrogant and ideologically driven is
this administration in Congress that
they adopted a budget that will create
nearly 20 trillion dollars in debt over
the next decade which the Congressional
Budget Office declared unsustainable
this was done at the same time the
Federal Reserve pumped the trillions of
dollars into the financial system
current fiscal and monetary policy has
turned America into the largest debtor
nation
the world has ever known it threatens to
destroy our currency through inflation
The Full Faith and Credit of the United
States government and the Liberty
opportunities and security of future
generations born and unborn that is a
contemptible disgrace and they're not
done as further evidence of their
compassion and good deeds Obama and
Congress are in the midst of
nationalizing 17% of our economy better
known as the health care system the
government has already run up over 55
trillion dollars in unfunded Lobb
legations for Social Security Medicare
and Medicaid entitlements now how do
they justify this well they do it as
they always do everyone should have
affordable quality health care and the
only way to accomplish that of course is
for the government to take it over and
that's what Obama and Congress are doing
and promising by the way have you
noticed that the status can't quite get
his propaganda straight on the one hand
he promises national health care that
will ensure quality care for all
Americans on the other hand they say we
spend too much on health care and we
need to cut out test medicines
procedures technologies that are too
costly well which is it do we spend too
much or do we spend too little it
doesn't really matter does it they don't
really care do they John Cassady writing
in the left-wing New Yorker the other
day put it this way so what does it all
add up to the US government is making a
costly and open-ended commitment to help
provide health coverage for the vast
majority of its citizens I support this
commitment and I think the federal
government spending parties should be
altered to make it happen he writes but
let's not pretend that it isn't a big
deal or that it will be self-financing
or that it will work out exactly as
planned it won't he said many Democratic
insiders know all this or most of it
what is really unfolding
suspect is the scenario that many
conservatives feared the Obama
administration is creating a new
entitlement program which once
established will be virtually impossible
to rescind at some point in the future
the fiscal consequences of the reform
will have to be dealt with in a more
meaningful way but by then the principle
of universal coverage will be
well-established even a 21st century
Ronald Reagan would have great
difficulty overturning it and as the
great Milton Friedman explained once the
whole population is covered by health
insurance there's little political
incentive to increase spending on
medical care once the bulk of costs have
been taken over by government as they
have in many other countries the
politician does not have the carrot of
increased services with which to attract
new voters so attention turns to holding
down costs in other words rationing
expenses explode services denied the
Iron Fist
is put in place for the status this is
the ultimate authority over the
individual he is always craved once the
individual is entrapped the status
controls his fate the individual be
seduced by the notion that he's
receiving benefits from the state when
in reality the government is simply
rationing benefits the individuals
tethered to the state relying on it for
his health and survival not only does
the government have an ownership
interest in his private property but not
only has one in his physical being I
should emphasize the extent to which the
status policies are demonstrably
devastating let's look at the
environmental movement because it
requires our attention the environmental
movement became prominent in the early
60s with Rachel Carson's book Silent
Spring
Carson was an opponent of pesticides she
asserted that the chemical DDT which had
been widely used to eradicate malaria
including in the United State
Europe and Canada destroyed wildlife
including birds and expose children to
increase rates of cancer in a 1972 case
brought by the Sierra Club to ban
production of DDT in the United States
an administrative law judge at the newly
established Environmental Protection
Agency found after listening to months
of testimony and evidence that DDT was
harmless to wildlife and people as used
under the regulations but his decision
was overturned by the EPA Administrator
William Ruckelshaus who hadn't heard any
of the evidence or read any of the
testimony but he banned it by himself
anyway as a result of this decision many
other industrialized nations followed
the United States and DDT became
unavailable to the third-world DDT that
had been used in places like Ontario and
Boston on playgrounds in the middle of
the day dropped from helicopters we used
to have malaria in this country you know
now this banning led to the death of
millions and millions of poor children
in Africa and Southeast Asia the Rachel
Carson remains an icon and the Sierra
Club remains a favorite media force for
expertise on the environment
environmental extremism kills and it
kills a hell of a lot of people and now
they move on to their latest which is
global warming which they now call
man-made climate change because the
world actually isn't warming it appears
to be cooling or most of us call it the
Four Seasons you know
for an Ann Arbor they call it the two
seasons summer and winter you know Obama
Congress in the EPA wanted to find as a
matter of law not science carbon dioxide
which you exhale as you breathe as a
pollutant which in turn must be reduced
and regulated and in order to do this
the federal government would have the
power to dictate carbon dioxide emission
levels and fine and punish those who
exceed them so in essence this would
empower the government to dictate
economic and personal decisions at
virtually every level of the society and
keep in mind carbon dioxide is actually
a very small fraction of greenhouse
gases do you know what the biggest one
is water vapor they haven't figured out
how to control that yet and yet without
carbon dioxide we would die the earth
would freeze because plants use it to
produce oxygen and now we have this
recent scandal these leading so-called
climate experts have been caught
red-handed and I do mean red-handed in
distorting temperature data lying about
warming trends destroying contrary
evidence messin with their so-called
models and smearing experts who disagree
with them it's a monumental scientific
scandal and unless you've read
conservative publications and listened
to talk radio you never heard of it and
the status could care less despite the
evidence Congress and the administration
are hell-bent on using junk science to
get their hands around our society and
control everything from light bulbs we
are legally permitted to use and
livestock flatulence you think I'm
kidding you ought to hear the farmers
who call in to my show
now as I wrote in Liberty and tyranny so
distant is America today from its
founding principles that it is difficult
to precisely describe the nature of
America's government it's not strictly a
constitutional republic because the
Constitution has been and continues to
be easily altered by a judicial
oligarchy except for Clarence Thomas
that most that most enforces if not
expands the status agenda it is not
strictly a representative Republic
because so many edicts are produced by a
maze of administrative departments that
are unknown to the public and detached
from its sentiment and it's not strictly
a federal republic because the states
that gave the central government life
now live at its behest so what is it
it's a society steadily transforming
towards statism if the conservative does
not come to grips with the significance
of this transformation he will be
devoured by it that said in the face of
this onslaught it would be suicidal for
us to abandon our principles we must
teach these principles they have been
passed to us from past generations and
have proven themselves throughout the
history of mankind these principles have
worked and no others now is not the time
for compromise who shall we compromise
with which principles shall we surrender
and to what end if we can't stop this
soft tyranny if we can't stand up to it
then when will we now is not the time to
lower our voices now is the time to be
heard loud and clear and if we are not
resolute now then we will never be
resolute all of you here
you're very intelligent you're motivated
people or you wouldn't be here your
society is under attack our governmental
institutions are being used against us I
know it upsets some people when I talk
this way but we don't have time to play
word games in my view we don't have time
to deny reality these people are trying
to dispirit you they're trying to
overwhelm you they want you to accept
their agenda as inevitable and they want
you to give up you are extremely crucial
in this battle you are the generals in
this battle whether you like it or not
it took decades to get to this point and
it will take decades to contain and
unravel it the status never gives up and
neither do we
we must become more engaged in public
matters it is in our nature to live and
let live to attend to our family to
volunteer and to quietly assist a friend
a neighbor even a stranger
these are admirable qualities that
contribute to the overall health of the
community but it's not enough anymore if
we're to win this struggle it will
require reinforcements a new generation
of activists larger in number shrewder
and more articulate than before who seek
to blunt the status counter-revolution
not imitate it and gradually in steadily
reverse course more conservatives than
before will need to see collective and
appointed office fill the ranks of the
administrative state whole teaching
positions in public schools and
universities and find positions in
Hollywood and the media where they can
make a difference in infinite ways the
status does not have a birthright
ownership to these institutions
we must fight for them mold them and
where appropriate eliminate them parents
and grandparents must take it upon
themselves to teach their children and
grandchildren to believe in and
appreciate the principles of the
American civil society and stress the
import of preserving and improving it
they will need to teach their offspring
that the status threatens their
generations liberty and prosperity and
to resist ideologically alluring trends
and in this regard back to this
all-important issue of language the
status has also become masterful at
controlling the public vocabulary for
example when challenged on global
warming he accuses the skeptic of being
a denier favouring corporate polluters
or being against saving the planet
draconian measures that threaten liberty
and prosperity such as cap-and-trade or
marketed in appealing and benign slogans
such as going green the status never
destroys he reforms he never
disenfranchises he empowers well this
has to end to President Reagan
understood the power of words he
deconstructed the status propaganda and
framed the debate on his terms
he once said how can limited government
and fiscal restraint be equated with
lack of compassion for the poor how can
a tax break that puts a little more
money in the weekly paychecks of working
people be seen as an attack on the needy
since when do we in America believe that
our society is made up of two
diametrically opposed classes one rich
one poor both in a permanent state of
conflict and neither able to get ahead
except at the expense of the other
since when do we in America accept this
alien and discredited theory of social
and class warfare since when do we in
America endorse the politics of envy and
division
someone on our side want us to forget
regular I say we still have much to
learn from him and Margaret Thatcher
and Winston Churchill and all the greats
that came before us we can stand on the
shoulders of Madison Hamilton Washington
Franklin Adams or Obama Pelosi and Reid
you pick let me close with a final quote
from Reagan which he gave oddly enough
dr. Arnn at Hillsdale College November
10 1977 it's the last quote in my book
he gave it in a speech called
encroaching control the peril of
ever-expanding government and if you
listen to my show I think we've made
this quote famous because I use it all
the time the freedom is never more than
one generation away from extinction we
didn't pass it to our children in the
bloodstream it must be fought for
protected and handed on for them to do
the same or one day we will spend our
sunset years telling our children and
our children's children what it was once
like to live in the United States where
men were free those words were prescient
let me just add this is a bloodless war
you want to know what an almost
impossible war was it was the Civil War
it was Gettysburg Vicksburg won burg
after another 40,000 50,000 casualties
in every battle the nation with 25
million people where almost every family
was touched the South was running out of
adult men you want to know what fighting
this enemy is like we have a
and battle on our hands in some ways
it's more complicated
there isn't a battlefield these people
are using the instrumentalities and the
tools of our own government against us
the unelected branches their four
branches of government if you haven't
figured it out yet
including the administrative state Larry
taught me that thirteen years ago he was
right the faceless bureaucrats had more
power than any other part of the
government that said if our ancestors
could fight as they fought in the Civil
War in world war one world war two and
subsequent wars surely we have the
resources and the grit and the
motivation to take on our adversaries
today it's a different battlefield it's
a different time institutions like
Hillsdale College are crucial they're
absolutely crucial as a matter of fact
Hillsdale College needs to be ten times
the size of this because unless we send
young Liberty minded people out into
society by the thousands how are we
going to win this thing unless they
understand what we just talked about
here tonight Larry and I and others how
are we going to win this thing we have
got to help the next generation because
to be perfectly honest with you this
battle that's being laid in Washington
against us today is mostly being laid
against the next generation they're the
ones who are going to have to pay these
bills they're the ones that are going to
lose their Liberty they're the ones that
are going to go without opportunity I
look at my kids 21 and 18 as you look at
your kids and your grandkids and I think
to myself if we don't take a stand right
now if we don't draw the line right now
if we don't for once and for all say
enough is enough and we will fight you
at every level we will use your language
against you we will go to the polls and
we will defeat you
unless we do that now I think it will be
extremely difficult to recover but
here's the good news there's more of us
than them there's uh and I'll say it you
may not want to put it in your
transcription they're more of us than
the brown shirts wearing purple shirts
over there across the hallway as a
matter of fact they're more of us than
acorn and the ACLU and the rest of the
left-wing kook groups put together but
we but we can't sit back anymore now
many of you don't sit back but your
neighbors do we'll wake them the hell up
your family members wake them the hell
up
you are the Paul Revere's if each of you
get another two three four or five
people interested in their their country
in their society we will overwhelm them
god bless you thank you Larry Arne and
Hills there